[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halbweg guten Abend und
willkommen Christian
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie
Meilenstein oder Tabubruch der
Asylkompromiss der EU-Staaten wird zur
Zerreißprobe für die Grünen
Putin spricht von ukrainischer Offensive
laut russlands Präsident hat Kiew mit
dem lang erwarteten Gegenschlag begonnen
und die nächste Anklage exos-präsident
Donald Trump muss wieder vor Gericht
diesmal wegen der Affäre um
Geheimdokumente
seit sieben Jahren versucht die EU sich
auf neue asylregeln zu einigen gestern
Abend gelangen den Innenminister und
Ministerinnen ein Kompromiss doch das
Echo ist geteilt erleichtert sind zum
Beispiel Kommunen sie hoffen darauf dass
bald weniger Menschen kommen entsetzt
äußern sich
Flüchtlingsorganisationen und auch Teile
der Grünen was beschlossen wurde fast
Christoph
ein Mechanismus beim neuen Kompromiss
ist wirklich neu schon an den
europäischen Außengrenzen soll es
Prüfverfahren geben konkret für alle
Migranten mit geringen bleibeschancen
etwa aus der Türkei Indien oder Tunesien
maximal sechs Monate lang würden sie in
Grenzen her festgehalten bis ihre Fälle
entschieden wären die meisten
Flüchtlinge etwa aus Syrien Afghanistan
oder dem Sudan hätten weiter das Recht
auf die üblichen Asylverfahren
wer allerdings abgelehnt wurde soll
künftig schärfer überwacht und schneller
abgeschoben werden und zwar nicht nur in
die frühere Heimat auch in sichere
Drittstaaten etwa wenn Migranten auf
ihrer Flucht dort durchgereist sind
Tunesien oder Albanien zum Beispiel
innerhalb Europas sollen die
Schutzsuchenden gerechter verteilt
werden über einen EU-weiten Schlüssel
Länder die sich weigern mitzumachen
sondern zum Ausgleich Geld bezahlen vor
allem in einem Punkt musste sich
Deutschland gestern der Mehrheit
geschlagen geben selbst Familie mit
Kindern könnten künftig an den
EU-Außengrenzen gestoppt und
festgehalten werden
vor allem die Grünen hatten die Ausnahme
für Familien mit Kindern gefordert der
Kompromiss jetzt trifft die grüne Seele
ins Mark Deutschland hätte dem nicht
zustimmen dürfen kritisiert Parteichefin
lang Koh Chef nuripur und auch
Außenministerin baerbock versuchen die
Wogen zu glätten Andreas Huppert hat
Reaktionen
seit 18 Monaten sind die Grünen in
Regierungsverantwortung eine Zeit in den
die Partei erkennen muss dass die
politische Realität oftmals politische
Vorstellungen zerschlägt Wärme wenn du
Ukraine Kriege Elektromobilität und
jetzt der EU Asyl Kompromiss wir sind im
Bundesvorstand in der Gesamtschau nicht
einig über die Beurteilung wir sind
kommen zu verschiedenen Einschätzungen
während Omi nuripur von Licht und
Schatten spricht sendet seine
kuhvorsitzende vom Kirchentag ein
deutlich anderes Signal das wenn es
darum geht auf der einen Seite dem Leid
einen Außengrenzen gerecht zu werden und
auf der anderen Seite mehr Ordnung in
Europa zu schaffen diese Reform nicht
reicht und dementsprechend hätte
Deutschland aus meiner Sicht gestern
diesen Reformvorschlag des Rates nicht
zustimmen sollen der Streit um Asyl und
um Menschenrechte innerparteilich kann
das laut und langwierig werden denn die
Partei ist bei diesem Thema gespalten
wie selten zuvor der Kompromiss wird aus
den auf dem Rücken der Menschen
ausgetragen der flüchten Menschen den
Außengrenzen Kinder die eigentlich in
der Schule sitzen sollen die können
jetzt an den europäischen Außengrenzen
Haft genommen werden und aus meiner
Sicht ist das für eine SPD-geführte und
von Grün mitgetragene Koalition unwürdig
die Außenministerin kennt den
parteiinternen Unmut schreibt deshalb
noch während ihrer Südamerika-Reise
einen Brief an die Bundestagsfraktion
darin erklärt sie unter anderem zu
Ehrlichkeit gehört auch kein Kompromiss
hätte bedeutet das gar keine
geflüchteten mehr verteilt werden
das war eigentlich schon immer Kern
dieser Partei bei schwierigen Fragen
sich der Diskussion auch zu stellen und
das war immer eine große Stärke von uns
die EU hat ihren Asylkompromiss
scheinbar gefunden bei den Grünen wird
das wohl noch ein längerer Weg
in Berlin einmal mehr müssen die Grünen
in dieser Koalition Federn lassen wie
sehr belastet das Partei und Regierung
ich glaube es belastet die Partei
erkennbar und sehr öffentlich und selbst
die Partei Spitze hat ja heute den Riss
sehr deutlich gemacht wobei der
Unterschied interessanterweise weniger
entlang der inhalteverläuft der äußern
ja beide Seiten Kritik viel mehr geht es
um die Frage was aus der Einigung folgt
für die einen weiterhin fundamentale
Ablehnung des Kompromisses für die
anderen pragmatische Zustimmung das sei
immer noch besser als der jetzige
problematische Zustand die mögliche
innerparteiliche Wucht die gründet sich
auf zwei Dinge erstens gehört die
umfassende Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen ja
quasi zum Erbgut zur DNA der Grünen und
die sei mit dem Kompromiss verletzt und
zweitens fühlt dieser asylbeschluss ja
bei den Grünen ein eh schon gut
gefülltes fast der Ampel internen
Frustration Stichworte evils AKW
Verlängerung Gebäude Energiegesetz auf
dem kleinen Parteitag nächste Woche wird
man sehen können ob und wie Ernst der
Frust auch für die Regierungskoalition
werden könnte
danke schön für diese Einschätzung aus
Berlin the war das
seit Tagen wird über die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive spekuliert heute meldete
sich russlands Präsident Putin zu Wort
die Gegenoffensive habe definitiv
begonnen sei bisher aber erfolglos
behauptet Putin auch ukrainische Quellen
berichten von schweren Kämpfen Christian
Volk
drohnenaufnahmen des russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums sie sollen aus
dem Süden der Ukraine stammen und zum
ersten Mal unter anderem westliche
Kampfpanzer auf dem Schlachtfeld zeigen
offenbar hat die Ukraine Leopard 2 aus
deutscher Produktion eingesetzt laut
russlands Präsident Putin gibt es seit
Tagen heftige Kämpfe wir können mit
Sicherheit sagen dass die Offensive der
Ukraine begonnen hat das wird durch den
Einsatz von strategischen Reserven der
ukrainischen Armee belegt seit Wochen
spekuliert die Welt über eine gegen
Offensive nun sehen auch Militärexperten
eine veränderte Situation der Einsatz
schwerer Kräfte mit einer Reihe
westlicher Panzer also es gibt ja
berichte über Leopard Panzer es gibt
aber auch Berichte über Challenger oder
über anderes westliches Gerät auch
amerikanische Schützenpanzer das deutet
alles darauf hin dass jetzt das beste
Gerät zum Einsatz kommt und das würde
die Ukraine nur tun wenn es jetzt
wirklich drauf ankommt also im Rahmen
meiner Gegend Offensive die konzentriert
sich offenbar auf das Gebiet südlich von
saporisha
hier könnte die Ukraine einen Keil in
die russische Front treiben und den
Russen so die Verbindung zur Krim
abschneiden aus Kiew keine Information
zu den Vorstößen nur so viel wir stehen
in ständiger Kommunikation mit unserem
Militär die Region der Netz steht vor
sehr harten Kämpfen und ich bin allen
dankbar für das Ergebnis ihrer
Anstrengungen
bislang habe die russische Armee alle
Vorstöße abwehren können teilte Moskau
mit unabhängig überprüfen lässt sich das
nicht
fragen wir unseren Reporter Tim Krüger
er war heute Richtung Front unterwegs
was ist dein Eindruck Tim
ja genau wir sind ja heute von saporicia
aus in Richtung Süden gefahren und waren
dann ungefähr noch zehn Kilometer von
der Front entfernt dort waren wir vor
zwei Wochen schon einmal aber jetzt
haben wir doch deutlich mehr
militärische Aktivitäten wahrgenommen
auch der Gefechtslärm war intensiver
also es ist ganz klar dass in dieser
Region heftig gekämpft wird und es ist
eigentlich auch klar dass die Ukraine
dort in die Offensive gegangen ist und
zwar so wie sie es seit langem nicht
getan hat es ist schwer zu überprüfen
wie diese Kämpfe dort verlaufen aber
wenn das wirklich eine größere Offensive
ist bei der die Ukraine versucht in
Richtung mehr durchzustoßen um die
Landverbindung zwischen Krim und
Russland zu durchbrechen dann sehen wir
eigentlich gerade den Beginn der wohl
wichtigsten militärischen
Auseinandersetzung in diesem Krieg
eigentlich seit den ersten Kriegswochen
vor mehr als einem Jahr danke schön Tim
Krüger nach saporische
in der Region Herr Sonne bleibt die Lage
doppelt gefährlich das
Überflutungsgebiet wird weiter
beschossen auf der von der Ukraine
kontrollierten Seite werden nach wie vor
Menschen und Tiere gerettet der
russische Katastrophenschutz
veröffentlichte Bilder von
Rettungseinsätzen auf der russisch
besetzten Seite dort sein knapp 6000
Personen in Sicherheit gebracht worden
überprüfen lassen sich die Angaben nicht
Russlands Aggression hat die
Landesverteidigung in Europa wieder in
den Fokus gerückt zeitenwände auch im
Luftraum über Deutschland dort beginnt
am Montag das größte Manöver von
Luftstreitkräften seit Jahrzehnten
250 Militärflugzeuge werden im Einsatz
sein Fakten dazu jetzt von Petra Riffel
trainiert wird die Verteidigung von
Städten Flughäfen und Häfen dabei soll
die Zusammenarbeit der 25 beteiligten
Nationen optimiert werden unter Führung
der deutschen Luftwaffe finden die
Übungen in drei Lufträumen über
Deutschland statt der Bereich Ost der
sich von Sachsen bis zur Ostsee
erstreckt der Bereich Süd der von Bayern
bis Rheinland-Pfalz reicht die meisten
der rund 200 täglichen Flüge wird es im
Bereich Nord geben weite Gebiete der
Nordsee gehören dazu
geflogen wird in einer Höhe von 2500 bis
15.000 Metern
Passagierflugzeuge fliegen in der Regel
zwischen 9.000 und 12.000 Metern
Ausnahme im Bereich Ost hier gibt es
tieflüge sogar unter 500 Metern hier
kann es sehr laut werden die Lufträume
sind täglich teilweise bis zu 4 Stunden
für den zivilen Luftverkehr gesperrt
hier kommt es zu Verspätung und
wahrscheinlich auch Flugausfällen
eine solch große Übung braucht viel
Vorlauf geplant wurde seit Jahren der
konkrete anlass war die Annexion der
Krim durch Russland das Ziel damals wie
heute eine glaubwürdige Abschreckung
über die letzten Vorbereitungen
berichtet Andrea Meuser
die Vorbereitungen sind fast
abgeschlossen 250 Flugzeuge wurden
binnen einer Woche nach Deutschland
verlegt darunter 190 Kampfflugzeuge und
tausende Tonnen von Material das größte
Kontinent stellen die Amerikaner dann
folgen die deutschen sie wissen diese
Übung ist Deutschland geführt das sind
zwar überwiegend Nationen die daran
teilnehmen aber die Übung wird unter
deutscher Führung durchgeführt trainiert
wird die gemeinsame Reaktionsfähigkeit
der Luftstreitkräfte durchgespielt am
Verteidigungsfall Deutschland das ist
eine große Gelegenheit hier quasi mit
dabei zu sein und die Lehren daraus zu
ziehen das geht also nicht nur um die
Frage von Solidarität die man politisch
zeigt sondern auch für die Militärs ganz
wichtig zu gucken funktioniert das alles
oder funktionieren auch bestimmte Sachen
nicht ein Zweck eines Manövers ist auch
immer zu gucken welche Dinge
funktionieren nicht was kann man noch
besser machen während des Manövers gilt
zu bestimmten Zeiten und in bestimmten
Gegenden Vorrang für die Militärflieger
zivile Flugzeuge müssen gegebenenfalls
warten die Deutsche Flugsicherung
übernimmt die Koordinierung des
fluggeschehens für den innerdeutschen
Verkehr bedeutet das dass bestimmte zu
bestimmten Zeiten möglicherweise Staats
verschoben werden müssen oder auch
Landungen verzögert werden müssen in
Lechfeld und Jahre starten und landen
die Kampfjets Wunstorf ist der
Einsatzort der Transportmaschinen 12
Tage geht das so die Nächte und das
Wochenende ausgenommen
nach Frankreich am Tag nach dem
Messerangriff auf Kleinkinder auf einem
Spielplatz in an sie sucht das Land nach
Antworten Frankreichs Präsident macron
besuchte das Krankenhaus in Grenoble wo
drei der vier zum Teil schwer verletzten
Kinder behandelt werden der mutmaßliche
Täter wurde am Vormittag psychologisch
begutachtet sein Motiv ist weiter unklar
nach Angaben seiner Familie ist er
schwer depressiv
als Donald Trump das Weiße Haus verließ
nahm er nicht nur ein paar
Erinnerungsstücke mit sondern auch jede
Menge Akten darunter streng geheime das
hat jetzt offenbar juristische Folgen
der Ex-Präsident sei in sieben Punkten
angeklagt worden sagt sein Anwalt
darunter Falschaussagen Behinderung der
Justiz und Verschwörung über Trump und
die Justiz
wohl wieder eine Anklage diesmal geht es
um die Geheimakten die das FBI im August
in Trumps Privathaus in Florida gefunden
hatte und wieder sieht sich der
Ex-Präsident als Opfer
sie versuchen unseren Ruf zu zerstören
um eine Wahl zu gewinnen ich habe nichts
Falsches getan wir werden kämpfen so wie
wir die letzten sieben Jahre gekämpft
haben noch liegt die Anklageschrift
nicht vor uS-Medien berichten jedoch vom
Vorwurf der Falschaussage außerdem sagt
Trumps Anwalt mindestens einer der
Punkte betreffen das us-spionagegesetz
ein Vorwurf betrifft Verschwörung eine
Verhaftung wird es aber nicht geben nur
eine Vorladung
viele mächtige Republikaner bleiben im
treu so beschreibt es der Sprecher des
Repräsentantenhauses als einen dunklen
Tag für die USA und selbst gegen
Kandidaten beim Rennen um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur stehen weiter
an seiner Seite
wir beobachten in den letzten Jahren wie
das Justizministerium als Waffe gegen
den Ex-Präsidenten eingesetzt wird
sollte Trump gegen das spionagegesetz
verstoßen haben droht ihm eine
mehrjährige Haftstrafe
das Verfahren könnte sich allerdings
lange ziehen auch bis nach den
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 und selbst
wenn es zu einer Verurteilung käme würde
das nicht unbedingt bedeuten dass Donald
Trump das Präsidentenamt nicht noch
einmal ausüben dürfte auch das müsste am
Ende wohl vor Gericht entschieden werden
das Bild des entspannt golfenden Trump
von heute morgen transportiert also
nicht unbedingt seinen Gemütszustand
denn ihm dürfte langsam klar sein dass
seine Taten in der Vergangenheit ihn nun
doch noch einholen könnten
blicken wir auf die Philippinen dort
sind die beiden aktivsten Vulkane des
Landes zum Leben erwacht aus dem Mahjong
steigt dichter Qualm auf das könnte laut
Experten auf eine baldige Eruption
hindeuten die Behörden haben begonnen
tausende Menschen in Sicherheit zu
bringen obwohl Siedlungen rund um den
mahjon nicht erlaubt sind haben viele
ärmere Menschen ihre Häuser dort gebaut
wir wirklich gute Medienprodukte für
Kinder sucht tut sich mitunter schwer
Auswahlhilfe bieten diese Experten sie
alle gehören zur Jury beim Goldenen
Spatz dieses Festival für Kinder Medien
findet jedes Jahr statt in Gera und
Erfurt der große Gewinner diesmal dürfte
bei vielen von uns Erinnerungen wecken
Daniela Sonntag
wer einen goldenen Spatz gewinnt hat
diese wirklich kritische Jury überzeugt
die insgesamt 34 Kinder kommen aus dem
gesamten deutschsprachigen Raum in
Europa erstmals auch aus Rumänien und
mussten vor einer Woche einen Schwur
ablegen
trenn geheim sehr viele Filme schauen
und sehr viel diskutieren ich habe
viereckige Augen das sieht man noch
nicht so gut und das lange Sitzen ist
wirklich
ganz schön anstrengend wir hatten nicht
alle dieselbe Meinung was aber auch
normal ist aber ja es waren schon heiße
Diskussion den Hauptpreis beim langen
Film dieses Jahr gewinnt Lassie ein
neues Abenteuer über die schlauste
Hündin der Welt der Ende Juli in die
Kinos kommt
auch besser Hauptdarsteller
ich war erstmal total überwältigt
über die Nachrichten und freue mich
jetzt eigentlich einfach nur noch es ist
die größtmögliche Anerkennung wenn das
Publikum selber die Preise bestimmt und
deswegen ist es natürlich auch eine
besonders große Freude das Festival in
Gera und Erfurt ist das größte seiner
Art in Deutschland neben dem Wettbewerb
auch ein wichtiger Branchentreff und
Blick die Medien Zukunft und auch eine
zdf-produktion gewinnt was ich nachts
träume finde ich morgens in meinem Bett
Weg Schreck die dreh die Zeit zurück
Maschine bekommt einen goldenen Spatz in
der Kategorie Serie
sehr schön jetzt zur
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft da gibt es
auch Action die hat in den kommenden
Tagen gleich drei Länderspiele vor sich
ne ich finde es gut für ein Teamgeist
also besser geht's doch nicht zu
Wochenbeginn geht es in Bremen gegen die
Ukraine mit einem Benefizspiel los live
zu sehen hier bei uns im ZDF die
Begegnung ein wichtiges Zeichen für
Frieden und Solidarität und für den
Deutschen Fußballbund auch eine
jubiläumspartie vor dem 1000 Länderspiel
in der DFB-Geschichte am Montag gegen
die Ukraine sieht Sportdirektor Rudi
Völler eine gute Mischung im Kader von
Bundestrainer an sie Flick diese
Verbindung von von von von Jugendlichen
Potential Unerfahrenheit aber mit mit
großem Engagement und mit diesen
erfahrenen spielen jetzt also bin ich
also ich habe ein gutes Gefühl so sehr
von seinen Gefühlen leiten lassen hat
sich ihnen Verteidiger Antonio Rüdiger
er beleidigte bei seiner Ankunft am
Mittwoch Abend einen Autogrammjäger ich
habe auch gestern schon mit Toni Rüdiger
gesprochen
zu dem Leiter hat sich schon
entschuldigt ist ein bisschen
rausgerutscht ein Ausrutscher zu uns
Zeit rund ein Jahr vor der Heim em
bemüht sich der Verband sichtlich um
mehr fanehren
ja und bereits morgen Abend live im ZDF
in Istanbul das Endspiel der Champions
League dabei ist Manchester City mit
Trainer pep Guardiola gegen Inter
Mailand klar favorisiert
sie sind das Team der Stunde Mitspielern
wie early Holland dem deutschen
Nationalspieler und Kapitän Ilkay
Gündogan und Kevin de Bruyne klarer
Favorit Manchester City das Team von
Trainer pep Guardiola setzte sich gegen
Top-Clubs wie Dortmund und Real Madrid
durch und jetzt ja
bildet sich einfach das Gefühl dass man
auch auch dran ist und auch endlich
diese Trophäe gewinnen will die berühmte
Außenseiter Chance ist jedoch immer da
auch Inter Mailand träumt vom Champions
League mit dem deutschen Robinsons Inter
besiegte Barcelona Bayern den AC Mailand
sie sind in Bestbesetzung seit April
ungeschlagen und das wollen sie auch
bleiben
und zum Tennis Novak Djokovic steht im
Finale bei den French Open in Paris beim
vierseits Sieg gegen den Weltranglisten
ersten Carlos alkaras Spanien
profitierte der Serbe von Krämpfen
seines Gegners und jetzt noch zur
Überraschung Leo Neugebauer hat bei den
amerikanischen college-meisterschaften
in Austin Texas den 39 Jahre alten
deutschen Rekord im Zehnkampf geknackt
er verbesserte die Bestmarke von Jürgen
hingsen um vier Punkte auf 8.836 Punkte
und steigerte seine persönliche
Bestleistung um erstaunliche 358 Zähler
das ist in Ordnung ja top Ansporn
natürlich auch für Niklas Kaul das ist
der Europameister danke schön das
Wochenende lockt mit Badewetter
Temperaturen zwischen 24 und 32 Grad nur
an den küstenkühler die Details und
potentielle Gewitter hat gleich Katja
horneffer das heute journal um 10 Uhr
mit Marietta Slomka die heute sagt danke
und tschüss und wünscht Ihnen ein
schönes Wochenende bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend auch heute sah der Satellit
über Mitteleuropa kaum mal eine Wolke
das sah hier in Osteuropa aber auch über
den zentralen Mittelmeer in Frankreich
und den Spanien anders aus da gab es
doch zum Teil kräftige shower und
Gewitter die Nächte werden bei uns jetzt
langsam milder aber rein und an der
Mosel sinken die Werte zum Teil nicht
unter 17 bis 16 Grad sonst werden 14 bis
10 Grad erreicht und einstellige 9 Grad
gibt es nur noch am alten Rand dazu ist
die Nacht meist klar morgen beginnt der
Tag mit sehr viel Sonnenschein dann
entwickeln sich einige Quellwolken und
vielleicht reicht's ja an der Elbe im
Erzgebirge auch im Bayerischen Wald am
Alpenrand vielleicht sogar mal im
Schwarzwald für einen kleinen
Regenschauer oder für ein kurzes
Gewitter der Winter dazu kommt das
östlichen Richtungen und so liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen direkt an der
Ostseeküste bei 21 bis 23 Grad sonst
werden 23 bis 29 am Rhein und westlich
davon 30 bis 32 Grad erreicht und in
diesem Wetter ändert sich am Sonntag
wenig die Gewitter beschränken sich dann
auf den Alpenrand bei 23 bis 31 Grad und
so bleibt auch die Waldbrandgefahr sehr
hoch im Nordosten in Niedersachsen aber
auch im Südwesten guten Abend